hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to deep down in space
another oculus rift adventure one that
I'm actually looking forward to because
this one like many of the other ones
that have scared the pants off of me is
randomly generated you may have seen
just there it created an entirely new
map just for me and just for me to cry
like a little baby as I wander through
these halls but either way I'm looking
forward to this one very much is very
highly reviewed and it's not often that
I get to play one of these good oculus
rift war games I feel weird when I'm
trying to address you in the games just
going through its intro sequence and I'm
not exactly looking at you but I'm gonna
ignore that because game is actually
started so we're gonna go right into it
hello blood on the ground that's always
a good sign for my future health well
alright then some giant is moving around
on the upper floors oh that is cool
you're the last game that I played those
are foe okay so that one is locked off I
got a AK I got quartz around my neck
that are restricting my movement
okay the scary room I want to go in
there come on let me in why not why
can't I go in the scary room it seems
like exactly the place that my fans
would want me to go because they're also
masochistic just like man does that one
say the Slater room is that another word
for slaughter room can I go to there or
am I just supposed to follow the blood
the cell the sound hide my demons as
they try to claw their way out of my
mind let's just wax art it whoa what is
that over there that might be the map
that was just generated let me take a
look at that first yeah so it's like oh
man that is that is bigger than I
thought it was there's a lot of detail
so I'm supposed to find seven of
something kind of like a slender hunt
fine D Duty thingy I'm gonna just wander
around because I've never played this
before I loaded it up just to get an
idea what I was getting myself into and
then I just started recording so here we
go in
the darkness come on bring it on okay I
can run so I can run head hello good
green means good whispering of demons
means good you're back to half off of me
but what the hell how about no nose a
good option
do you ever try it okay that sounds are
in my ears
oh okay what is happening and where also
why that doesn't
hi can you shut up for two seconds I'm
trying to concentrate if you stopped
crying like a little baby yeah one of
the problems with the detail of this map
that I'm noticing is that the high yes
who did that was that me why do I hear
so many crumblies okay so one let me in
the scary room but I think it let me in
the terrifying basement okay you need to
stop that right now
what is sale oh god it got dark why did
it get dark I'm trying to say something
here I haven't been able to say anything
okay so because this is the first oculus
rift development kit it's a resolutions
kind of low that's kind of evident in
this layout but I am lucky enough to
have the second developer kit be on the
way so that when I do these games in the
future not only will they be higher
resolution they will also I don't know
why I was shouting talking god dammit
stop going out there you stupid light
what what the hell that's jump
can you stop I don't know if that's a
real thing I just need to calmly and
collectively review this game as any
professional let player would and you
are being a big do sure about it okay
that was just a circle I am a [ __ ] I am
I should not call myself a professional
anything
is there anything actually here are you
just gonna keep [ __ ] with me the
entire time alright anyway so not only
will I have a high-resolution display
and I'll be able to show you these games
and I think 1080p but I will also stop
please I need to continue on with my
life
but also be able to move my head around
and give did I do that did I do that
also be able to move my head around
because it's got head tracking god what
the hell am I supposed to find there's
nothing here this is going in circles
reminds me of the bow opening scene of
Star Wars when Leia was hiding away from
all the do shoes should I jump down
there why dad God for me and climb right
up the walls apparently alright making
progress I got to that area that looks
like all the other areas I'm definitely
doing good
where the hell am i this does not have a
you are here sign alright whatever I
fell down in a trench I may be shut up
I'm gonna assume you're nothing until
proven otherwise
god damn it this is the most confusing
map I've ever seen in my life there's no
way than I'm ever gonna be able to beat
this game alright oh god a dead end that
a heartbeat I just heard why would there
be a heartbeat unless it was about to
stop is it my heart you better back off
my heart is like ten thousand hearts
strong stop it god damn it that's
legitimately freaking me out there's it
keeps sync and keep sounding like
there's something right by me oh you do
sure's god damn it this randomly
generated map is just throwing me for a
loop
can you not I need oh god damnit Hobbit
shouting what is that what is that what
is that what is that whoa god what is
that who's on my eyeballs what is that
one away what what do I do
what a Bogart no thank you what the hell
are you I saw something
it was like a muppet his head bobbed up
and down God what are you are you
friendly okay you're probably not
friendly but it's curious creepy okay hi
you see the top of your head there what
are you okay let's um what are you I
want to say I don't know if I'm supposed
to collect you if I'm gonna die
when I assume I'm gonna die where's my
flashlight keep going in and out I've
literally been shouting way too loud
into the microphone and like I just
looked at my waveform and it's all just
like solid bar so I hope that doesn't
sound like an ass for you guys I'll try
to edit it a bit hi yes good yes good
can I go beer good yeah Oh dick with me
[ __ ] my life
god damn it oh my god I'm still alive
holy [ __ ] tits on a cracker
oh that was the girl I hurt myself
taking my oculus rift off Jesus huh
jump I fall I climb up these walls yes
god damn it don't do that to me you
douche shut up good lordy Lou
what else does was that what is that
there's a thing there's legitimately a
thing I don't want to move I don't want
to go anywhere but I have to I'm a brave
man shut up you little kid if you are
the guy god damn it I don't I I'm
getting paranoid take my guys shut the F
up I'm gonna move 10 steps if you could
just give me a second
stop being a giant douche er let me go
just gonna go just gonna go i'll leave
the area okay apparently i'm gonna
circle back into this exact same area I
was just at know how to go up I'm gonna
go back down I'm not making much
progress I seem to be wandering in a bit
of a circle over and over and over again
and everyone's gonna kill my giblets
okay since the safe area where's my
flashlight keep fading in and out let me
just stare at the map for a while I
collect my thoughts T's [ __ ] you
god damnit ur dick what am I looking for
I'm guessing those red dots are either
dead ends okay they're dead ends the
green things maybe maps so there's two
maps here and two naps there so I'm
assuming I'm in that middle hallway
there so what the hell do I do I'm gonna
try to get to those circular rooms maybe
God David I thought I was dead so bad
okay so I need to go down this way shut
up shut up shut up jump [ __ ] okay okay
so these are the two maps or three yeah
three maps I need to go all the way past
the third map make a left
yes shut up this is the way I came
wait no I don't need to go back up I
need to go this way cuz I was a
staircase right okay so I just need to
go the shut up goddamn it you noises
noises Dusen in the dark he's not do
that
oh god this games making me freaking
paranoid man I need another map I don't
know where I'm going I need to go down
and write maybe through that door yeah
shut up with your moaning oh god damn it
why can't I get anywhere
I can't open any doors they're all
locked maybe that's the point it's not
exactly a game you can finish it's just
hopelessness by the way did I even
mention there's a story to this I don't
think it did you're like the last
surviving member your ship is defunct
and you gotta get out somehow don't ask
me how I don't know oh good I love the
long series of tubes what I was that's
the Internet
those are clever reference I made
goddamnit no no no okay
don't you do that are there so many
doors what is that is that something I
need yes yes yes I did it and I forgot
those instructions that I could put down
markers so I can see where I've been so
okay been there I got a red and a blue
one is that another one oh my god I'm
actually making progress
Kurt Junkers pulls that I saw something
did it move
something was in there I think no no
thank you
another circuit okay I'm making progress
I got three of seven okay I'm out of
breath but that's okay so that's good I
don't know where I am but I think I'm in
that back area no I'm in one of those
circular chambers so let me go the other
circular chamber maybe the other maybe
they're all down here okay shut up I'm
just I'm fixing this ship just God geez
give me a moment no come on okay nothing
back here
oh god that sticks to the wall that's
cool I'm gonna assume that the noises
are nothing I do not know what the hell
jumped in from eyescreen I just know
it's probably gonna happen again
sometime
well I'm ready for it bring it on in
fact actually bring it off would be god
damn it there's no markers of where it
could be okay this is a map I am at the
last circular chamber so goddamn I guess
I'll go try to get back to that up shut
up I guess I'll go try to get back to
that area on the right over there oh god
damn it you freaky frackers shut up
you're not real
you're just in my mind they're not real
they're not real I'm real I may not be
real this may all be the matrix I'm just
oh hello okay so this would be the one
at the end of the hallway and there's a
circular chamber over there so I need to
make left then right
Oh God push
bush owner if I have unlimited of these
probably not but they make me feel
better a little blue balls amazi better
not come out I got my blue balls here I
will be to blow ham side what is this
what is that I don't know what that is
well this is a series of dirt this is a
series of doors I came to her let me go
up here okay this looks promising we
need four more take some red light I
don't have a green light and looks like
you're one of those nodes so you're just
gonna have to permanently stop oh god
what am i doing what's happening stop it
get off of my face I don't know what
happened okay alright that's cool
ah ah thought I heard something that was
cool let's um how the what the in the
hell did I do oh god not again no no no
no no no I'm good I'm real good I'm good
I'm good you know what I'm good I'm good
I'm good I'm good
you know in fact you know in fact I'm
good that was just the opening sequence
that wasn't anything I know that was I
know what that was that was the opening
sequence that's what I was I'm taking
that off I'm never putting that on again
Jesus Cristo ah my hairs mess I'm ugly
give me a second I need to fix myself up
hello there thank you all so much for
watching that was legitimately the
biggest scare I've ever received in my
entire life so I hope you enjoyed it and
if you did please leave a like down
below for my suffering thank you all so
much for watching and you can check out
more of my oculus rift horror games in
the description below or through that
annotation over there so thanks again
and as always I will see you in the next
video
well I can't do that